Those of us who live in this
amazing world of science
and engineering have got
to pay more attention
how to speak to the public.
I am convinced one
approach is to embrace
the value of the visual--
that when we find better
vocabularies to express
complicated ideas,
there will be less confusion
across the globe about how
to make critical
decisions that will affect
our health and our planet, to
educate all our cultures on how
to distinguish between
opinion and fact.
One approach is to engage the
public in our conversations.
And we can do that creating
honest, accessible, compelling,
even beautiful images
of our research
so that our work will
become less intimidating,
where your mother
or father will not
be embarrassed to ask
questions about the images they
see of your work.
That's part of the
philosophy of this course,
in case you didn't notice.
But so much of what we do in our
labs is difficult to explain.
So first, here's where
I'd like to briefly touch
on the potential of
visual metaphors.
For example, you've
seen this music box
throughout this course.
I made the image for our
book "No Small Matter"
to engage the reader to
think about the language
of computation, a binary
language, either on or off,
as this music box's
clever system works.
It's either one or zero.
Take a good look
and think about it.
Here's another one
of these metaphors
along the same thinking of
explaining binary language.
These are small drinking
glasses viewed from above.
The ones filled with red
(good shiraz, by the way!)
represent one in
this binary system.
The empty glasses
represent zero.
Again, for the book,
"No Small Matter."
The first row across represents
12 in our everyday number
system.
If we add the second row, 22,
the result in the third row
is 34.
12 plus 22 equals 34.
Here's another
you've seen before.
We call it etching
with light, suggesting
how some surfaces we work with
in the laboratory can be etched
with various patterns.
And here, this
cascade could suggest
how the flow of electrons
change from one energy state
to another.
Here's one I think
that works quite well.
These graduation chairs
are lined up basically
to guide parents where to sit.
It's a metaphor for
something called templated
or guided self assembly.
Just as when DNA replicates
itself, each of its strands
guides the distribution of
bases for the new strand.
Here's one that I
did love making,
but maybe it doesn't
quite work enough.
I wanted to show the
counterintuiveness
of quantum mechanics.
Now, look at the
shadow on the right.
It doesn't make sense, right?
In fact, that square
shadow is impossible.
I made it with software.
And so it is with quantum
mechanics-- so much
of the quantum phenomena simply
just makes no sense at all.
Here's one from
the Fermilab which
I thought was quite clever.
Take a guess at what this jelly
bean jar is metaphorically
representing.
Take a moment.
And the fact that it's from
Fermilab is a big hint.
So here's that information
in a pie chart--
of course, more quantitative.
We are seeing the distribution
of dark energy, dark matter,
and everything else
in the universe.
I think we pay more attention
to the jelly bean jar.
Do you?
What do you think?
Now, none of these
visual metaphors
work completely on their own.
First, we need some
sort of text to help
us look and think about it.
And most important,
all metaphors
fall apart at some point.
And that conversation
of where they fall apart
can be a powerful place
to talk about the science.
I encourage you
to start thinking
about creating metaphoric
photographs that
teach the non-expert
how to start
thinking about various
scientific phenomena.
OK.
Let's switch gears
and look at just a few
simpler ways to engage the
public with our images.
How about using some of
your new wonderful images
of your work for cards, or
announcements, or posters?
Could be fun thinking about it.
The images you will begin
making after this course
will be pretty compelling.
I'm sure of it.
Why not show them off outside
the research community?
All I suggest is
to think about ways
to incorporate some of
your amazing new images
in ways to excite the public.
And who knows?
Someday, you might
even get an exhibit
along the Champs-Elysees.
What do you think?